good afternoon everyone this is your cat
many people in the rich world are
wondering when they'll next be able to
go
on a foreign holiday and while the
answer to that remains
unclear what's more certain is that
travel
in the post-pandemic world will be
different
so what will the key changes look like
and what do they mean
for holiday makers business travelers
and those working in the industry
[Music]
monday afternoon on the beach sonja came
to the canary islands for a short break
last
year and decided to stay
the pandemic has changed how many people
think about travel
and its relationship with their working
lives and sonia is one of a growing
number of travelers who are now
mixing business and pleasure thanks to
the growing acceptability
of remote working before i was head of
sales
i was basically all the time
very busy and when i
i first arrived it was like for me
perfect
sonja is combining a prolonged holiday
with working from la palma
one of the smallest canary islands
we try to find the balance between
working and also having a good time and
enough time to breathe travel and see
more about the nature
according to travel firm expedia
three-quarters of americans would like
to combine
work and a holiday and some in the
travel industry
think working holidays offer
opportunities both
now and in the future
nacho rodriguez runs the house sonia is
staying in and says
business is booming
we've seen a humongous increase in
demand
a lot of knowledge workers that were
based in dublin in
in london they decided to to relocate
and visit
uh warmer places like the canary islands
the outlook is bleaker for those
offering more traditional accommodations
such as hotels and resorts
tourism accounts for 40 of jobs on the
islands
but the number of visitors in december
was 81
lower than the year before in the past
few months
nacho has helped hotel owners fill their
empty rooms with remote workers
and even the regional government is
coming to him for advice on how to get
more people to the islands
certainly the interest of the regional
government has increased
because traditional tourism weren't
common
therefore they had the urge to to
understand what other alternatives
they they could promote but it remains
to be seen
whether the numbers of people combining
work and a holiday
will rise in the post-pandemic world
and for now this is only an option open
to a privileged minority
so it will take much more than an influx
of digital nomads to restore visitors to
pre-pandemic levels
the reason for this is that the
devastation to international travel
caused by kobit 19 is like nothing seen
before
prior to the pandemic the number of
international tourists had been rising
fairly steadily for the past 30 years
but last year the number of people
traveling dropped to levels last seen in
the 1980s
and one sector that is suffering as a
result is air travel
when we had the 9 11 terrorist attacks
or the global financial crisis
we didn't see air travel fall by more
than three percent
in a calendar year whereas last year it
fell
66 percent
no one can say when or even if flying is
going to recover
the best guess from industry trade
association iata
is that flights could be back at 2019
levels in the next three years
but the recovery could take much longer
the prospects of recovery for long-haul
flights look particularly grim
this is because long-haul carriers rely
on business fares
to subsidise the cheap seats at the back
of the plane
and the pandemic has hit corporate trips
hard
according to a poll conducted in
december 89
of firms had cancelled most or all
international business travel
and although this may pick up the
consensus among most analysts
is that between 20 and 25 percent of
work trips could be gone for good
which is bad news for legacy airlines
business travel is a really important
sector particularly the long haul
airlines because it's really the driver
of profitability it's the driver of the
financial viability
of the roofs several long-haul carriers
have already been bailed out with state
aid
[Music]
but it's not clear what happens when the
money needs to be repaid
so fares on some long-haul routes look
set to rise
meaning fewer people will be able to
afford exotic holidays
but the outlook for short-haul flights
looks sunnier
the sect is set to make a quicker
recovery
many budget airlines are less reliant on
business fares
some like europe's largest airline
ryanair have used the pandemic to cut
costs further to keep their fares low
we've lowered our labour costs we've
lowered our aircraft costs we're
negotiating recovery discounts
with a lot of our airports and fuel is
lower i think it's the most exciting uh
era in my
25 or 30 years of this business
but michael o'leary's predictions that
planes and beaches in europe could be
busy as soon as this summer
may be going too far and have more to do
with his
famous salesman bravado
the company has just had to pull this
advert for encouraging travellers to
break covert restrictions
so you could jab and go and the
emergence of new variants of the virus
means
travel in europe and other parts of the
world is currently getting harder
not easier thanks to restrictions such
as quarantines and border closures
the virus looks set to be a feature of
life for years to come
and that makes one significant change to
travel likely
you'll have to pack more than just your
passport in future
some in the industry believe travellers
will have to carry proof of vaccination
to leave the country
[Music]
but these so-called vaccine passports
are not without
problems the rate at which the world is
being vaccinated
varies and some poorer countries will
not get the jab for several years
meaning they could be effectively shut
out of global travel
you start requiring vaccination or
vaccines
as a prerequisite to travel we believe
that that's unfair
and that's going to drive discrimination
and that's going to be
impacting not only in travel but in
other areas
another possibility is that you'll have
to travel with a new
app on your phone to prove your covert
status
a variety of digital health apps are
currently being trialled that translate
a negative covert test
into a qr code allow travelers to prove
their covert free
quickly and easily
[Music]
and in time they could become essential
to travel as a passport
it should allow trust
that the traveler you know has been
tested
and that should give governments the
confidence to
you know remove any restrictions and i
think that's a sort of critical
next step for opening up markets
in the meantime the drop in travelers is
giving the tourism industry
a rare chance for a reboot many
destinations are rethinking the type of
visitors they attract
and considering how to make tourism more
sustainable
in amsterdam the city is considering a
ban on non-residents buying cannabis
to attract a better class of tourists
machu picchu in peru is introducing new
visitor limits
and barcelona has run a campaign to
encourage people to venture away from
the old
the city agenda is another one that has
been accelerated which is great
it's not only the government it's not
only the private sector it is also the
traveler that needs to be more
responsible
the traveler now needs to make sure that
the impact of their trip is
benefiting more the community
back in the canary islands nacho is also
thinking along these lines
by encouraging visitors to some of the
less well-known islands
hi sonia how are you how are things
going
this is the first time he's hosted
people on la palma
and he hopes this interest in slower and
more sustainable travel
rather than mass tourism and package
holidays will continue beyond the
pandemic
we have to think that the canary islands
receive almost 15 million tours in
in 2019 so that's a lot of people and
that's actually
in some way unsustainable people
consider that economic
side of things most of those torpedoes
are based in the in
the home countries so they're the
benefit of of those people traveling to
the canaries
not necessarily stays in the local
community
getting travel back on its feet is not
just about holidays
it's a multi-billion dollar industry and
the backbone of the globalized world
building back in the right way could
mean both a more seamless experience for
travellers
and a more sustainable future for the
industry that supports them
i'm simon wright industry editor at the
economist
if you'd like to read my special report
on the future of travel
please click the link and take a look at
our film
on green aviation thank you for watching